yes we've been taking your questions
during the summit and before and we're
going to put them to so these guys here
and these people are Linus upson the VP
for Chrome Hiroshi look I'm a DVP for
android our new Weber the engineering
director for Chrome desktop and mobile
Darin Fisher chrome platform engineering
lead in Ellison Taylor director of
product management on the web platform
and eric k director of software
engineering on chrome apps extensions
and Native Client and I'm Jake just just
Jake I feel like a smoke I feel like a
small child at New Year who's been
allowed to stay up till midnight with
all of the adults is it's great so we're
going to go through the questions as
well if you have related questions or
comments or you feel like you know
someone hasn't answered the question
properly then please tweet about it use
the hashtag or which is chrome dev
summit or tweet directly at chrome dev
summit and the internet Paul Irish is
going to be monitoring that and he's
going to be using these internet powers
to direct those questions on to this
screen and I'll read them out so okay
let's get started with the first
question so developers can build for the
web for web views on native how should
developers decide which to use do you
want to miss offline I'll take a stab at
it mmm I think ultimately it depends on
what you're trying to accomplish and so
it's all about picking the right tool
for the job for many applications you
want to write a native app on a mobile
device for many other applications you
want something that exists on the web
just a link away in a web browser other
times you want to be able to share code
across different platforms both the web
and on mobile and so you want to be able
to use web view for doing development
but what we're trying to do is just give
you the best of all possible tools to
get done what you want to get done
mm-hmm just to add to that you know we
noticed in the Play Store that a lot of
apps actually use web view a huge number
actually of apps big proportion of apps
already use web view so it all it may
also not be either/or choice like some
apps do both you know in the app
depending on what the screen is and what
you're trying to do so a hybrid approach
i think is good too i agree completely
with Linus so if we were building
something like a short website for a
shop which would use what what kind of
what kinds of properties of the
of the apple or product will you use and
decide which which to use iweb webview
native what kind of what kind of
properties I think you know so the
obvious ones are if you're building a 3d
game you're probably going to be
building on native for mobile if you're
going to be building something that's
very text intensive and layout intensive
the web is probably a much better tool
for solving that job so it really
depends I mean there there's thousands
of different kinds of apps and there's
hundreds of different dev stacks out
there and and you know you just need to
pick the right one for the job hmm
because I mean we're getting free d on
the web now as well right we've got
WebGL it is are we seeing the web as
being something that's that's going to
grow and take away from native or as
they're always going to be you know is
always going to be a use case for native
or is the way is the web trying to take
over from native or is a different use
case um it it depends the you know we
saw this play out on desktops and
laptops before it's not as if native
apps went away when the web came about
but the web enabled a whole new set of
use cases that you couldn't do inside of
native applications the the guys who
started Google Maps originally we're
building a windows app and then they
figured out hey you know we can do this
on the web and because of the lack of
friction on the web where you can get to
anything by just typing in a URL or
clicking on a link yet many more people
who could use maps easily cuz they
didn't have to download install an
application and so you know depending on
what you're trying to do and I think
another example i heard recently was
Ticketmaster so they actually spent a
lot of time and effort and built this
really great mobile app but most people
don't buy tickets every day they buy
them like a couple times a year and so
that's a use case where they probably
really want to be on the web and our job
you know as the chrome team is to make
it so they can deliver you know an
experience as rich and and immersive as
you'd get a native app but you know not
force the user to install an
applications they're only going to use
once or twice a year so no one ever
questions we had is some developers
choose to build native apps rather than
for the web because of because of
performance and what we're doing to
address that and you know so this
performance difference that we see
between chrome
native apps is that a fundamental
problem with the web or is this is this
something that we can that we can fix
why don't we ask Darren since he's
responsible for fixing it it's aldarans
fold there you go you know absolutely i
mean performances one of our biggest
focuses and it seems like the area of
great opportunity this this web
rendering engine was designed in the air
of desktop computing and bringing it to
mobiles been you know a challenge and
but it's one where there's a lots and
lots of opportunity to make the system
work a lot better it's actually very
interesting if you think about the web
web platform is this retained model
where you describe your scene and if you
described in the right way the browser
can do it can actually do a really good
job of rendering it the problem is
there's just a lot of ways in which you
can describe things incorrectly and end
up in a situation where met you might
get a pretty rendering but you don't
actually get a rendering where it
animates well and so there's a lot of
challenges for us to not only make it
faster but help developers find that
fast path and and stay on that fast path
and that you know we're looking at all
these things it's both changes that have
to be done in the system performance
tuning and tooling that is available to
developers there's some there is also
the security model of you know dangerous
api's and when you talk about you know
some of the some of the powerful
capabilities that you have with native
installed applications today we don't
have a security model on the web that
supports those api's and that's why you
know we have installed packaged apps for
Chrome OS and why we have native apps on
Android and that that we have a security
model that now supports sort of user
choosing to get this thing so until we
solve that problem you know that that
divide is going to continue to exist as
well I mean we can see night native apps
doing things like animation and
paintwork and it seems really fluid and
yet really fluid so what what is it
about the web that seems to make this
slower there's lots of historical things
that have been challenging right and
lots of areas where you can see the
engines have gotten faster and better at
handling those sorts of things you know
for example you know people are familiar
with using CSS transforms to break up
their application into various layers
where each layer can be retained by the
end
then you can perform an animation and
the engine is smart enough to move that
layer without forcing a repaint even if
you're writing a native application on
Android you're still thinking very very
much thinking about how do I avoid
repaints how do i carefully carve up my
application so that the various GP
resources can be used and don't have to
be recreated and all that sort of thing
it's actually very similar in the web
except you know it sometimes it's harder
for developers to actually see where the
memory is going where the different Alec
where the different how the layers are
set up and so on so it's definitely a
challenge for us to make sure that
that's more transparent to developers
and help them stay on the fastpass just
to add to that it's also really easy to
write a really poorly performing app
natively as well so just because you
write a native app doesn't mean you
automatically going to get good
performance you have to have that in
your mind as you're developing your app
even at the OS level you know it last
year i think it was we launched jelly
bean with project butter many of you may
have heard of that that was a concerted
effort on our part to make the operating
system really smooth and buttery and
that took a lot of work and its aim at
the app level at the native level as
well as web apps hmm so we saw Paul
Irish before showing the the layers
panel right so what we're starting to
get these tools to show developers so
you know what's actually happening under
the hood which letters being created
what else are we doing I mean we see on
native like we get these really fast
scrolling lists by you're reusing memory
for things that disappear off screen are
we going to get something like that on
the web sure I mean I think the the sort
so-called infinite list problem is is
certainly a challenge where you want to
basically keep creating new content as
you scroll through a viewport and that's
an area we've been we've been actively
focused on we see sort of a lot of as we
explore that we see a lot of low-hanging
fruit you know the renderer spends too
much time on XY and Z and we can
eliminate that CPU cost help reduce the
cost of painting but also we can add new
primitives to CSS and we've talked a lot
about ways to help developers carve up
the Dom so that the costs are more
limited but these are areas of anyways
these are areas of active exploration
and it's it's not really clear exactly
what the solution will be but it's one
that you know we want to make this very
easy because it seems like it's a very
common pattern is there anything in
particular that
you know people are trying to make a
performant web app mrs. something they
should avoid doing because of the
performance avoid repaints I think there
was a DA genk free org and a DJ king
talk by net and Tom and they probably
i'm sure they talked a lot about this
hmm ok so moving on to the next question
other plans for bringing chrome based
apps to android as an alternative to to
native apps i guess is one so you Eric
well we already yes we have a solution
for that and we talked about a little
bit before which is using webview and
through Cordova so with we've been
contributing to the Cordoba project for
the last year and a half and really
trying to make it a better experience
for Android and iOS and part of that
process as involved making it more
modular making it easier to have plugins
and one of the sets of plugins that
we're going to be providing is a set of
of modules that allow you to bring all
the chrome apps api's to your court of
apps so we have a bunch of examples
actually up in our github repo it's sort
of show the same code you know that you
would just repackage through Cordova and
you know have it running both on your
desktop and on iOS and Android so that's
packaging abusing using a separate
program and that'll turn it into an
Android native app is there is our
entire for Android to natively support
the chrome perhaps well I mean to my
mind it is natively supporting it right
that basically the Play Store is where
you get apps for Android right so it's
not like we want people to have to know
to go oh I go here for some of my apps
in this other place for the rest of my
apps you know having them all be in the
play store makes a lot of sense and for
the developer you know packaging this up
it like i said it literally is the same
source code so from their standpoint you
know the difference is just what what is
the end package that's produced and
where do they upload it to now i think
that we've been investigating more ways
that we can you know coordinate the
developer experience between you know
play and Chrome Web Store and like maybe
have shared developer consoles and that
sort of thing don't have anything to
announce on that front but I we continue
to look to make reduce developer
friction yes as you say we've got the
Chrome Web Store and the play store and
there's you know is this this is a
fusing model having vote for them is
there any plans to to unify the two so
there's no plans right now to unify the
two you know I think you know again for
Chrome there's a you know a place where
you go to get your chrome stuff your
themes your extensions your apps for
Android there's a place to get your your
phone and tablet stuff I think you know
to some degree we've looked into what it
would look like if we tried to merge
some of these things and it winds up
being a little bit confusing you have to
add multiple hierarchies of which device
am I looking for and which stuff do I
get we might figure something out in the
limit but i think you know from from a
user standpoint we want to make sure
that if if users go to one store or the
other and they're looking for something
else that we can give them the pointers
back to so they find things in the right
yeah i think that's one of the things
we've seen right now we don't end up
with android users in the Chrome Web
Store going where's my android apps or
vice versa so I don't think it's a an
issue for users hmm so um we've been
hearing about the the new chrome based
android webview in some of the sessions
in the past couple of days it doesn't
auto update is that that's correct right
there are other plans is that under way
so yes photo that has been a one of a
major feature of comb over the years and
definitely something that we want to do
for web view as well we are facing some
significant challenges and we go we
don't have a date to announce but we are
actively working on it yeah we have we
have a process within chrome with the
various pre-release channels plus a
bunch of internal testing and things
like that to make sure that if we break
someone's website we find out before we
go push it out to hundreds of millions
of users I think one of the challenges
we have with auto updating webview is
there's this whole ecosystem of Android
apps that use web view and if we're
going to be updating that thing very
rapidly we need to have mechanisms to be
able to test all of those applications
and and get feedback early in the
development process to make sure we
don't go break a whole bunch of them
when we push out updates but this is not
a problem on the web right i mean we
update the browser all the time and and
other browsers update all the time is it
why and we've got massive automated
testing infrastructure to see what we
break and stuff like that during the
development process before it actually
gets out to users and also with these
early release channels like the canary
and
channel and beta channel people can come
and yell and say a file a bug you broke
my website you bastards and we can fix
it before we go send it out to a whole
bunch of users and we don't have those
mechanisms and processes and
infrastructure in place for you know
testing against the whole ecosystem of
Android apps yet and so that's one of
the big engineering challenges we face
and process challenges we face and being
able to do that cuz we want to get there
we haven't figured out all the problems
yet and so how do we distribute
something that big across all the device
or the OEMs all the networks the curves
so it seems like getting the new chrome
webview on there was was kind of it was
a big challenge right it's been it's
been the old Android browser for for a
long time now I mean we got Chrome as
the default browser but we still had the
old webview what would the challenge is
there what yeah what were the real
problems and why do we see the the
chrome webview having a kind of slightly
different feature set to the chrome
browser and basically it was another
part of chromium to something different
it's a single process environment it's
it has it's a slightly different
graphics architecture there are very
small differences by the way which are
WebGL WebRTC and the add web part for
canvas 2d and by the way we're walking
activity to fix those and make them just
like there's a chrome moving forward so
because it's a single process model I
compared to in to Chrome how does that
affect performances or Israel
performance difference now um there's
the only difference but the only
difference i'm aware of his canvas 2 d's
again which is using a software path so
far other than that justin is actually
simpler and then where we are in comas
or start a problem so in you can put
like the webview into a hardware
accelerated know it or leave it in a
software mode absolutely yes is why
would people why would people do that
why was there why are so many people
using a software mode and neat on the
old webview sorry well no I mean it's
simply because they want to read back to
it often because they want to read back
the bitmap or the rendering and they
want to do their own processing with
that if you're if you're in that
situation where your goal of using the
webview is to get the
souls then perhaps software rendering is
better for you if you need because you
know if there's a hardware read back
it's going to be slow I've seen that
before because then i had a canvas time
on that i wrote a number of years ago
which was analyzing the pixels in every
frame and it was it was running at 60
frame well about 30 frames a second a
few years ago and then the switch won't
made to Hardware canvas and all of a
sudden the demo just completely died
it's like that part of the same thing
yes sure exactly so it has a lot to do
with the use case if you're if it's a
webview usage where it's all about
display then the GPU path is going to be
great and the other interesting thing
about the webview just the way it's
integrated it's integrated in it so that
it acts like an Android view and that
definitely affects the way it renders so
it tries to conform to that API any rate
there's a lot of other subtle there were
a lot of other challenges to getting the
chrome codebase to provide a good
android webview and a lot of it had to
do with compatibility the the Android
webview is a very you know an
established piece of code where a lot of
applications are depending on a large
volume of Android applications using it
and using it in subtle and interesting
ways ways in which perhaps it wasn't
originally designed and yet we had to go
and discover those ways and make sure
they were still supported that's it's
all been very fascinating all right so
it's like a different next question and
I'm sorry if I sound bored reading it
out but I'm really really bored of it
what is the current stands if any on
moving responsive image implementations
forward likes or set I feel like this is
I feel like what what's going to happen
is that we're going to reach the layton
we will launch the responsive image
solution it will be standardized and
then that's it we run out of numbers for
yours that's it the time has ended you
know we've run out of time to do do
anything the universe will implode on
itself did you read blinked if yesterday
no I didn't know anyways them there's a
lot of active discussion on on this
topic in a source and source said so on
I think from chromis point of view we'd
love to find a great solution here you
know as people have been talking about
this more and more more more refinement
of the use cases it's sort of you know
come out and people are again circling
on the right solution
it's really important to us that we
don't end up with three different ways
of doing responsive design in Chrome for
images we would really like to find one
good solution that addresses the
majority of the use cases that all the
browser vendors can feel good about and
adopt that would be a lot better than us
shipping all and and you know we've been
there before were like we have three
different ways of specifying CSS
gradients or gradients in CSS and that's
unfortunate and here with responsive
images we want to also be thoughtful and
responsible with the platform and yet
find it find a darn solution because we
know that people are hungry for this
hmmm I kind of feel that maybe the
working group discussion hasn't been
completely fruitful for this could we do
something like get a few like balls and
one for each of the responsive image
solutions put some cat food in and then
just bring a cat in and whichever ball
the cat goes to we just do it as I like
the way you're thinking yes that's an
interesting one you know recently you
know there was the source and proposal
and that's been chopped around and you
know there's been interesting feedback
from the the WebKit folk and that's
going into the you know people are now
taking that into consideration then
pitcher sort of came came up again as
hey maybe that will solve all our
problems and then Hicks is like what but
you guys realize multi element solutions
are really painful for x y&z blah blah
blah the whole thing circles around that
I do feel like we're there's a lot of
motivation to solve this problem so
developing web apps is quick becoming
more and more complex and low-level what
steps are you taking to keep web
development high level without making me
as a developer after delve into paint
operations and GPU cycles and I love
this question because it's so loaded I
mean I can talk a little bit about that
I think we've kind of talked a lot about
that and last last day or so I mean
because we love all that low-level stuff
as well we're kind of going in both
directions giving you more low-level
features if you really want to get
closer to the metal and that's the whole
sort of you know WebGL being the classic
example but then we're doing these
higher level things as well you know
adding we've been working obviously on
features like flexbox and grid and then
coming up to web components and now
polymer so we're trying to kind of come
in without having to
but to have these different layers that
you can come in that depending on your
particular scenario so you can get up
and running really quickly but you can
still get access to the low-level API is
if that's what you you want to do and
you can start 11 layer and work your way
down so we're kind of coming at it from
from different different angles yeah
exactly like I feel like it's part of it
part of the answer is let's make the low
level less scary and more accessible
better tools that sort of thing because
you know like it or not you often do you
really need to understand what's going
on but then things like web components
gives us the substrate for which weekend
and developers can other people can
provide components that people can use
that hopefully solves the problems for
people who don't have to fight through
them that other people part is also
really important because we obviously
were huge supporters of our own polymer
effort but the idea behind web
components is that loves it there can be
lots of providers for lots of different
use cases we're not going to implement
every widget known to man or woman so
there's going to be lots of we hope lots
of third-party support given web
components allows interoperability
between these different frameworks
that's very cool we've not had double
yeah and I think as an example like
Mozilla X tags can play nicely with
polymer components on the same page at
the same time yeah many third-party
vendors have come out and said yeah
they're getting ready to build the
Rhines or web components and frameworks
that can then can interoperate yeah I
mean not to beat it to death but the
cool thing about web components is it's
just like custom HTML tags and all these
frameworks that already have existed
since you know the big since forever
they all work with HTML elements so they
all work with web components it's really
cool you think about it you can hurt you
don't have to throw away what you're
already doing and just sort of gently
embrace parts of you know things done as
web components it's actually really neat
I think it's an idea in this question
that web development should you know
should be high level I mean I remember
working in in places where you had
developers who just did sort of HTML and
CSS and then you had saw the number set
of developers doing doing JavaScript and
you know none of them are really caring
about sort of the low level paint stuff
is that is that no longer possibilities
are we saying that no young we you know
developers need to maybe grow up or is
the other different different jobs I
think that I think that goes by
to one of the earlier questions about
you know why are native apps faster than
the web well it turns out in many cases
you can get exactly the same performance
on both platforms if you know what
you're doing and the the problem is is
like a Darren mentioned earlier there's
many many poorly lit paths through the
wet web platform where if you go
wandering off in there bad things are
going to happen to you and so doing
things like web components in polymer
gives us the opportunity to give
developers a high-level well lit path
that's also highly performant because it
stays on all the fast paths inside the
blink and inside of chrome Hiroshi is
this is there this miss feeling in the
native old as well I know nothing about
it is the other sections of developers
who feel like that kind of low level
thing it isn't something they should be
caring about because if you've got
primitives on Android as well and you
can sort of do extra things with them
other developers who are saying look I
shouldn't have to be caring about this
stuff it should just do it yeah and this
is this is similar to the point I was
trying to make earlier which is it's
it's actually pretty easy to write a
poorly performing app for native as well
and as a native developer you have to
pay attention to these same things and
they are poorly lit a lease on the
native were in the native world as well
and you just have to be aware of this
stuff and and this was a big part of
what we pushed last year with jellybean
again you know with this big push on
project butter we have new tools we had
new tools that we made available so that
people can trace the developers can
trace what their app is doing and figure
out what the bottlenecks are it's all I
think the same concepts it's just
different sets of technologies but it's
really the same thing I think that's
also there's cultural differences in the
developer communities as well I think
historically web developers haven't
cared about 60 Hertz animations it just
hasn't been on people's radar it's not
something that you just expect from a
website but if you're a mobile developer
that's something that you've expected
from day one and so you you go okay you
start thinking about how do i get sixty
Hertz and then start adding features on
top of that whereas many web projects
they go out all their features and then
go holy cow how do I make this fast and
and so one of the things we try to do
inside of Google with lots of other web
developers inside the company is get
them onto the fastpass first you know
get there hello world the very first
thing they get going on all
right fast paths and keep it passed
through development as they add features
and capabilities and round out what
their program does because it's much
much harder if someone's been hacking on
HTML CSS and JavaScript for a year and
then they turn up and say hey I'm really
slow and I use a lot of memory can you
help me it's much easier to start fast
and stay fast and have automated tests
to make sure that you stay on those fast
paths as you keep adding things to it in
terms of like getting smooth web
performance from the web and developers
not really it's something we've been
pushing the past year that developers
have to care about this and and it's
been a new thing too many developers is
that a culture that we've created not
not chrome specifically but sort of
browser manufacturers that it just
wasn't possible for so long but knee you
know the web assist this fairly high
level pretty slow thing developers
couldn't do anything about it have we
created that culture of you know just
throw tags on the page and just hope it
works well I look I feel like you know
if you look back at the way the web
developed and the innovation on mobile
that happened where people said hey
fixed position elements don't have to
suck because they can get their own
layers and you know overflowed scroll
can actually get its own layer that sort
of promotion of things that took to
their own layers so that they can take
advantage of GPU acceleration avoid
repaints that sort of thing is very
novel and necessary in the touch
environment and it's something that
wasn't there with desktop rendering I
mean the old way of rendering chrome I'm
sorry rendering web browsers was rest or
raster as the whole thing and if there's
damage we rear a stirred the damaged
part and it didn't take into account the
fact that you know there might be
separable layers and all this sort of
thing if scrolling happened we shift at
the bits and we're Astor eyes the
exposed region I mean there was no
pre-rendering down the fold so that you
could efficiently scroll these are all
new techniques techniques that are
essential on touchscreen touch devices
mobile devices or underpowered laptops
you know you sort of see just that's
where that's where the industry is going
a lot of users are on these low power
devices we had to make the web rendering
engine work well there and it does mean
changing a lot of things we've had to
make some breaking changes the way fixed
position elements were
today they now we've we've made them
create their own stacking context which
was a spect breaking change necessary to
to allow for better performance and for
chrome you know it's been this evolution
of getting more and more of these mobile
ideas these sort of have them actually
applied to desktop and we're getting
there so to the core of your question
about low level versus high level you
know the primitives versus you know
these high-level concepts one of the
things that that we've seen is that when
you when people start with high-level
concepts and then they want to change it
in a way that the high level construct
didn't allow they start having to hack
their way around it and and that's the
kind of thing that winds up actually
contributing to some of the performance
issues and and so if instead you say
well every it's okay to have high level
constructs but they're built up out of
primitives that we expose so if you want
to recreate that high level thing or
pick and choose and take bits and pieces
of it you can do that and that's part of
the what we're doing with web components
is that even though it hides things from
from you you can still drill in and get
into it and take it apart and do
something different with it that you
don't need necessarily to start at the
high level you could start at the low
level and build up from there so I am
yesterday I was like ripping into
application cache for its manifest
format where you add a line to it and
you you've set up routing and caching so
about all at once and it's not it's not
always clear that you've done all of
that all you know that one line doesn't
doesn't read like it should do all of
those things we have translate Z 0 which
you know as an API says I want you to
move this nowhere on the Zed index but
that's promoting something to a GPU
layer is that another example is that
one of those kind of API is that's kind
of doing something it shouldn't perhaps
one of the things that we've been really
excited about is trying to identify sort
of more of the bedrock of the web
platform you can see the work that's
happening with service worker you're
very familiar with this Jake the all the
all the stuff there that's thinking
about app cache v2 or app cache exploded
or finding the primitives in app cache
and giving those to developers so that
something like app
ash can be explained cleanly I think
stuff like translate Z 0 is kind of like
this as well although that one is a very
indirect way of saying what you mean
hmmm it really fixed position elements
should just it should just get promoted
and and ditto for overflow scroll and so
on and so forth but yeah in general
we're very interested in trying to find
the to not to be careful of these sort
of high-level api's that trap you and
and limit actually your flexibility I
mean high level api's can be really
great for giving you guy Grails but you
need to be able to sometimes step step
aside and find the and do things
differently than what the API designers
were thinking I mean I've cash is just
the greatest example of this but there
are plenty of other examples in the
platform so you know the more we can put
developers and control the better I mean
they can the more we can enable
developers to create frameworks or web
components right that that allow other
developers to be more successful that
just makes everything go much better if
everything is gated on improvements to
blink we're not going to go very far so
lately I've had developers ask for like
a specific API or CSS rule or something
for promoting an element to a GPU layer
but I suppose that would that would be
tying it to a particular are well
there's a real cost to that right so if
you if a web page says hey I need this
to be a GP layer well what happens when
you'll have enough beer am yeah and so
there's definitely this challenge of
making sure that we don't create a
platform that we're going to regret to
also part of the reason that we have
this sort of translate Z role is that
one day we could reverse that and do
something else do something faster that
isn't specifically promoting to a GPU
layer yeah I mean it is just a promise
that it be rendered in did it appear a
certain way right if we don't have the
memory to do it we can't do it cool we
might sorry I really like the rendering
forms is part of my things I think I
probably let that question ride longer
than it should have by the way there's
another example like this where the the
problem is sometimes that when you when
you give developers this thing it says
that looks like make this go faster they
will liberally sprinkle that over their
code yeah and the problem is that as a
platform that the limits what we can do
to optimize things so a classic example
of this is that
you know some some languages with
garbage collectors in the past had a way
of invoking the garbage collector of you
saying do it now and the problem is that
that often is like the worst thing to do
that garbage collectors can be very fast
if they can look at the patterns that
decide when to do things and how to
migrate stuff from you know old space to
new space and you know our new space
told space rather and all that and if if
the developers constantly saying no no
GC now GC now you're you're actually
slowing things down not speeding things
up so sometimes hiding some of these
input implementation details there's
actually some benefit to it this
conversation is really fascinating to me
as the native android guy because it's
exactly the same stuff that happens in
the native world writer so it's it's
fascinating one thing I think I'm
surprised no one mentioned it the blink
tag I think that's what caused the
problem because this one for a second I
mean come on we've nothing to do with
blinking a branding engine right yeah
yeah we're not responsible for that who
do we play for us Michael it was in
Microsoft in netscape it's someone else
right it's not nice so Android has this
codified design design guidelines for
application design right are there any
plans to release a dedicated UI
guidelines for Chrome apps or extension
development Erica you know so so polymer
is probably where you're going to see
this so so polymers are real really are
our bet for sort of saying not only are
we can provide components that are going
to be really easy to use and really
powerful and really perform it but
they're going to have a nice opinionated
you know look and feel and that we're
going to set you know you know animation
curves and we're going to set spacing
and font selection whatever now again
because it's the web you can ignore all
that and do whatever you want but but
the whole point is to make the easy
things easy we want to have that well
that path we want to guide you towards
something where if if you just want to
make something it looks nice that you
can you can do it easily i think that
the bottom line is we want the default
to just be beautiful and just to have
something that you'd be proud of just
for no effort and then second layer
being that well now you want to maybe do
some easy customization you don't have
to rewrite everything just the normal
CSS that you know and love today will
work and then there's the layer below
this is ok now I you know I want
something really customs I'm going to
use the lower level primitives i'm going
to use animation I'm
use something lower level to really
customize it but it you don't have to
rewrite everything it'll all just just
hang together yeah we've had this
discussion inside the team for four
years where you know the web is kind of
like designed on the web is kind of like
evolution in the tropics I mean it's
where you know really crazy organisms
evolved and and many of them are pretty
hideous but some of them are really
spectacular because there's no guiding
UI toolkit for the web from the very
beginning I think it's very different
than most other platforms where there's
this a standard system toolkit and when
you use that you get all the apps sort
of have a very similar look and feel and
and and and stuff like that but usually
very often the most popular apps on each
platform well then step outside the
toolkit because they want to do some new
and innovative thing on the UI and so we
see these things coming at it from
opposite directions but with polymer
we'd really like at least they're to
being a widely deployed option on the
web where you can have more similar and
more standardized look and feel I if I
download an app for Android or iPhone
and I see that they decided oh no the
buttons should go you know at the bottom
and they should be purple really you
know they've changed the they're
different now from other apps and this
this to me it looks like a bad thing and
but that's not true on the web right
it's there's there's so much sort of
innovation in un design if we brought
the web to to have a more standardized
field would we'd be losing something or
would it make it easier to use well I
think both and what what will happen on
the web is some people will use it
you'll start to see more commonality
between sites where people are putting
in a lot of effort but usually most of
the popular places are going to heavily
customized I think you'll see the same
thing in native and on the web but on
the web they just having that haven't
even had a standard tool kit to choose
from so it was just impossible so we at
least want to give that option so how do
we deal with user expectations with
regard to offline web apps because so
you know if we fix this thing with
service worker and we you know you could
say in some way in some cases you can
fix it with application cache there's no
there's no user expectation they're like
no one opens a browser when they've got
no connection and expects it to work
what can we do to fix that well there's
a couple ways to think about offline
so whenever when people typically when
they say offline they tend to think oh
I'm on an airplane I'm somewhere far
away from a network i have no network
the most common offline use case is
actually the use case where my network
is just bad or it's mostly good and just
occasionally bad or there's a hotel
proxy that got in a way or something bad
happened that would cause an
interruption and technologies like
service worker and even application
cache in some cases can can smooth those
bumps out and make it so that you don't
notice and and that's I think a key
innovation for the web regardless of the
entry point now that said when you are
offline really offline I agree this is a
big problem that web browsers don't
address well today and it's actually one
of the reasons why we did packaged apps
is because we did in the way we did is
we pull them outside the browser give
you a surface on the desktop like a
native app to remove some of those those
barriers because if you think about it
it's not just the there's there's a
couple of barriers you have to get
through one is the psychological thing
of well should I even launch this
browser I know I don't have a network
and everything's going to be broken it
all my restored tabs are going to be
busted so why would you even do that to
begin with and if you decided you were
going to do that then how do you
navigate to your thing well you did you
memorize that URLs you did you book
market for many people they search for
it they use a search engine and guess
what if you're offline you can't search
for it and and so even just navigating
the normal use Peck use case where you
navigate to your offline enable app is
now broken and so so so that's part of
some of the motivation with what we did
with packaged apps that said I do think
that this is a problem we can solve and
you know or improve i should say
probably not solve because it's unlikely
that we'll ever get a significant
portion of the web really offline
enabled think wikipedia or google search
these are things which fundamentally are
just not going to catch themselves
completely offline and not going to be
well what the problem is is even with
native apps now most everything all the
popular things people do require a
network connection I mean sure I can go
look at old tweets when I'm offline but
I mean quietly if they update in the
background in the old
ah now you gotta power question so if i
have 100 apps doing that i've got a
problem mmm yeah if so did we find the
Daath line working in the chrome app
space is that users actually expect it
to work without a connection um yeah I
mean it does mostly work now again the
the trick about it is again it's not
necessarily about does it function does
it have all the features that the app
would have it's more about does it not
break right and does it recover
gracefully you know when you launch you
know Skype you know and you don't have a
network connection you don't expect to
be able to do a video chat right but you
wouldn't expect a white rectangle that
says like 40 4 or something yeah exactly
and you expect that oh if the network
reconnects that the you that it'll
suddenly wake up and start to work you
didn't have to find a reload button or
refresh or quit the app and restart it
right and and and that's the kind of
thing that yes it is working quite well
with but I think the key to what what
Eric said is so we've done tons of user
studies we've have lots of customers who
are using various Google Apps offline
the big thing is is they need an access
point outside the browser and when they
click it they can't launch a browser cuz
the browser is just full of landmines
when you're offline there's hardly
anything you can touch that will work
when you're offline and so having be in
its own window and having a dedicated
access point to it are sort of the key
things for doing genuinely offline type
applications so if yeah you're right if
i open skype or whatever and it was just
a blank window i would consider to be a
broken experience i've had no connection
if i open a browser and I've got no
connection i type in the URL it says you
know it does that that was like yeah
I've got no connection the difference
between the two is an icon in the space
where I would expect to find like apps
on on that platform it's not just that
it's it's also as Linus was saying it's
it's the affordances in the browser it's
the address bar and bookmarks in all the
land mines the back button the back
browsing tabs and the menu could I mean
view in chrome apps there is a URL bar
North i installed tweetdeck it can open
as a tab right if
chrome URL so that's a difference
between sort of the what are what we did
in v1 which was hosted apps which were
really you know just web pages with you
know some additional you know built-in
you know permissions to it with packaged
apps there is no URL bar it's completely
outside the browser and you know
standalone windows so blink established
some some guidelines for how new
features should be introduced like
covering like the compatibility risk and
things like that you know what other
browsers are saying and lately have been
some discussion around the possibility
of the dart VM going into to Chrome
what's the plan there who's brave sure
so the one of the things we set out to
do from the beginning with both native
client and dart was we wanted people to
be able to write code that would run in
all browsers so we wanted to be will
have a path where we can compile C code
down to the JavaScript and and run it in
all browsers including chrome we want to
be a people to be able to write dart
code and run it in all browsers by
compiling it down to JavaScript and so
you know the capability of being able to
work in these other languages is useful
to a number of developers and so we
wanted to enable that and that was sort
of the baseline for it but then going
beyond that you say is JavaScript really
the best vm to execute c code in I mean
it's possible but II are you going to
get the best possible performance by
doing that and will you be able to do
things like threads and and and other
things similar questions come up with
dart we can compile dart down to
JavaScript but that might not be the
fastest way you can run the language and
so the dart team basically took on a
challenge that said we're not even going
to think about putting the dart VM into
chrome unless we can show dramatic
performance enhancement both in terms of
startup time and in terms of execution
performance and then and so that's what
they're working on right now and also we
want to do it in a way that doesn't add
a tremendous amount of complexity to
blink and the rest of the web platform
it needs to be done in a way that's
essentially orthogonal to everything
else that's going on because we can't
just keep bolting in New VMs left and
right if we end up
some horrible n squared dependency mesh
so that's the way we're looking at the
problem we haven't made any explicit
decisions yet about what we're going to
do but that's how we're thinking about
it mmm so I'm my knowledge of pinnacle
is actually quite low but I mean I got a
feeling that this is for i can write in
in you know whatever language i'm most
comfortable with and compile it down to
do something you know and if we can run
really really fast does is that
something that could happen with with
dart i mean would we need to put the
dart VM in tacoma mean we do we just be
able to you know compile it using
something like pinnacle is that is that
like one solution that we cover both
cases well I mean the dirt the dirt tjs
is already actually doing this quite
well you know if you look at some of the
benchmarks they're doing and some of the
the tree shaking and other whole program
optimizations that they're able to do
with dart tjs they can make programs
that you know take a dark dart and make
it dart program and emit j/s that's much
faster than handwritten equivalent to
Jas is so in some ways they're they're
moving that way really pinnacle is it
certainly could be used for that and and
it's possible that we could get you know
you know comparable performance and
honestly though if they can get you know
do it with with JavaScript it's I mean
basically with Pinnacle the the security
and platform portability that you get
with Pinnacle would just make
implementing a vm like a modern vm on
modern java vm javascript vm dart VM in
pinnacle just would not be as fast in
that environment is if you implemented
it natively mmm and so there's some
another interesting thing which is just
that darts one of the Doug darts goals
is danger act with the Dom needed to be
in very much an alternative the
JavaScript right whereas with Pinnacle
it's a plug-in architecture it's very
much asynchronous too what's going on on
the main thread where the Dom lives and
and so it's just very different you
wouldn't be able to actually take the
dart VM and and run it in that plug in
context and have synchronous direct
access to the DOM and so it's just a
different environment so pinnacle
doesn't have direct access to the Damas
like a sandbox two runs asynchronously
to everything so for performance is
there any kind of equivalents or post
message ring to sort
as per semester GPA I'm basically just
asking questions of mine because my own
ignorance about faces to hook now I
should get back to actually questions
people people last and it does turn out
that this one is about name maybe was
great go to the pinnacle session yeah
you know maybe watch the online stream
yeah there's a problem like between all
of the sessions I was busy writing the
intro for the next session so I i I'm
assuming this was a good like summit I
don't really know right look at the
feedback later like well we tell them
recorded right so i can actually just
you know i'm off next week i'll just do
that my my girlfriend actually hate that
if I just spend the whole thing watching
dead videos I'm actually banned from
using a laptop next week any plans for
sporting Native Client in chrome on
Android because not there at the moment
right yeah we don't have any plans right
now you know to be honest you know we've
been focused on the desktop weave in and
making that experiences because we can
and you know and i think you know right
now android does have a you know a great
solution for delivering native code on
it already so it didn't have the same
you know needs you know that that we had
in the web of filling in the gap in
terms of in a browser you know Clank
right now is I think really focused on
being you know smaller faster more
efficient and so you know and it has to
like you know try to get as much as a
web platform in it as we can so again
we're taking our time with thinking
about things like this clinic is come
400 ah yes sorry as I used a code name
so now someone we took isn't isn't it
like a firing you got fired if you leak
a code name for a project right is that
that yeah okay so I I am I actually
remember I got out drinking with a few
friends and this is in London and I was
making my way back and it's just like
midnight i was quite drunk i was on the
underground and i just got talking
someone you know i don't i don't really
speak to people when i'm not drunk but
on this this time I was right now yeah
yeah I was I've you know had a few
whiskies before I came here I just tell
you guys a story I thought we could do
if a break no no but someone I was
talking to someone and they they weren't
working
in the web or anything and they said to
me that there there boy friend had told
them not to use chrome because of memory
usage that was that was actually the
first time I've heard that but I've seen
it since so are we doing something to
decrease the memory usage in chrome and
like if you have multiple tabs open it
is especially a case on mobile right
yeah I think I the memory issue there's
two things going on one we always need
to use less memory than we're using I
don't care how much we're using we need
you to use less and we have lots of
dashboards to track it and continually
working to drive things down too though
because of chromes multi-process
architecture there's a lot of
misinformed reporting about how much
memory chrome actually uses because
there's a lot of shared memory between
those processes and and so if you really
want to measure the memory usage of a
complex system the the gold standard way
of doing it there's a page on chromium o
argh I can't remember exactly where it
is that describes how to do this which
is basically you you get a system you
have to completely qui a sit you look at
how many pages of RAM or actually in use
and then you run your experiment and you
ask the operating system okay how many
pages of RAM are actually in use now
because some of the memory that's
allocated by the browser is actually
held in kernel space some of its shared
between multiple processes so you got to
make sure you count it exactly once and
so you basically have to look at it from
the whole operating system layer and
find out you know during your test what
was the beginning memory usage and what
was the end memory usage and and see
what that is and so so the first thing I
get frustrated because people keep
sending me these blog articles about
like combs using 10 gigs of ram it's
like no it's not and well some people
have a lot of tabs open but the other
thing we found out as we make chrome
faster and make it use less memory which
we have over the years people open more
tabs and web applications use more RAM
which is another problem but anyway well
we recently had a big project to reduce
memory usage particularly on mobile and
I had a lot of benefits on other
platforms as well so yeah it's incoming
31 and it's really part of the kid get
ready switch main focus was to run great
on 512 thing about
devices and so cone we had a very large
or folder on this and we reduced me
Maurice instigator and we have a pretty
ambitious project going on involving
improving the garbage collection of
basically Dom object wrappers basically
today the DOM is is a reference counted
and javascript is garbage collected and
they can the garbage collector can get
it can take it awhile to learn that
there's a bunch of garbage it that's
outside of the garbage outside of the VA
teeth that it can actually release
references to this is the oil pan
project that you might have heard of on
blink dev and we're very excited about
opportunities there to improve keep the
steady state memory usage down of
applications that do a lot of Dom
traversals or or whatnot there's a
related problem to that line is kind of
alluded to which is that oftentimes
memory usage is really the web pages
using a lot of memory the web pages are
doing more advanced things they're there
now now growing and I think one of our
responsibilities is improving the
developer tools so that developers can
diagnose these problems more easily and
we've been adding a bunch of things to
chrome dev tools to help users
developers find memory leaks and to
identify large growth and to fix those
problems yeah and I think the other
thing is is you know users I don't think
should have to be responsible for memory
management I want to open 100 tabs why
can't I open or tabs i think the browser
can get a lot smarter about a victim
things from memory that aren't being
used it's difficult to do as a nap on
like a piece of Windows or Mac because
you you don't know what else is going on
in the system and you don't want to
necessarily be throwing away memory is
because there's there's some other app
like they launched Photoshop and it
flushes all of your tabs but you know on
platforms like Android and Chrome OS
where we have a more holistic view about
what's going on in the system we can be
smarter about you know managing the
total memory usage and consumption of
the browser yeah I get myself into a
state sometime really but the tabs get
so small that the icon disappears and
that's what I have to really think about
where my life's heading it's like
sometimes I don't have ID
chrome open like and I I'm going I'm
about to open it you know because i've
restarted the machine or whatever i look
over at my roots are at home and it just
like puppy dog eyes and it shakes his
head as i tell you what i'll disable
Wi-Fi then open chrome and then turn
Wi-Fi back on and just go to the tab i
need so you need help yeah so packaged
apps is one mechanism for to adding
richer api's for like web view maps you
in doing that sort so we've called over
phonegap but also packaged apps just on
desktop so we got this add to homescreen
thing as well that just puts an icon on
the home screen but doesn't really give
it anything else it doesn't give any new
AP Isis is refuted do that I have the
actual installation step that grunts
like six or api's so let me talk about a
little bit actually 3931 beta and info
to beta and hopefully is gonna be on
entry to stable there is a new meta tag
you can use in fact as a developer to
prompt the user to say hey do you want
to install this on your home screen so
so the way there is a way to do that
today the idea of giving enhance
permissions to an application that's
installed this way one of our goals is
to try to UM you know one of the really
cool things about the web is that that
you can just get up and using that
application very quickly and then only
sort of bother the user with with
prompts when they actually want to you
know get access to some capability and
so we're excited about you know as we've
been doing for a while adding more
capabilities to the web and I think that
that whole home screen things is an
important part of like giving web apps
that that presence on the on the launch
surface that the user is going to and
then think about you know launching an
app that the permissions problem does it
doesn't necessarily have to be coupled
to the way in which you launch the
application yeah i think the the core
challenge that we face is really
squaring the security model of the web
with the capabilities app developers one
right we need to be safe to click on
links but app developers want then
access to everything and so I think that
is that is the hardest problem we we
always deal with things like these
performance issues memory usage all this
other rendering performance they
these are places where there's a linear
path to make progress on and I can see
the lines converging over time the the
inherent split between every link is
safe and I want access to send smss from
your phone you know that is the hardest
problem we deal with so you mentioned
like having a meta tag to say that
something is web app installable is is
that because I know I'm aware of the
tags to say like it's capable it can be
added to the home screen and maybe
appear without like a URL bar and things
Apple have got one that will actually
sort of show an advert for like the
native app equivalent over the top is is
that okay we do we advertise the fact
that this can be installed to home
screen and you'll get something like a
different experience so it's really
we're the ties of fact that these web
page can be added to your home screen as
a user and then we can get back to that
web app from the Home screen hmm in
terms of the one of the things I called
it out in it in my talk having the sort
of the slam door when you visit a
website that says like ya know we've got
the information but it's an extra click
away just because we want to tell you
about our up again is like I've have a
decent solution to that they've got this
sort of banner across the top is that
something are we looking at implementing
that or something similar yeah I mean
we're all tremendously frustrated by
that you got your inner browser I have
no desire to install the app I just want
to use this thing once and I have to go
through this interspecies like hey
install my app we want to make that go
away and we're looking at a bunch of
different ways both technological as
well as social and and and you know
various economic incentives and stuff
like that so that people don't you know
put those barriers in front of users and
they do the right thing for users often
those interstitials even break deep
linking it's very very frustrating right
I think we're going to move on to our
last question so why have something that
we're not adding any new CSS prefixes
right that's but blink we're not going
to add a new some more notes link prefix
there's not one there but but we've got
some api's that still have me and one of
the ones it's likely you've got CSS
transforms and animations and they're
left behind a WebKit prefix an IE and
firefox ership done prefixed
right yeah so there's a there's a bug on
this and has a lot of dependencies our
goal really is to UM prefix these
particular set of WebKit prefix CSS
properties once they're up to the
standards basically we don't want to
take away the prefix until we we are
shipping the thing that is compatible
with what these other browsers are
shipping so we have a set of bugs to go
through before we could do that it's
actually a tremendous story because if
you look at the blink dev thread here
it's a very much a community effort I
think one of the guys from Intel is very
involved in doing some of the work to
make this happen as well as folks from
google I think we're all excited about
getting to a point where we can take
away WebKit prefixes and you know we
might keep the WebKit prefixed version
around for quite some time because
there's there's a process for
deprecation and figuring out once nobody
really would care if we remove it that
can take a while yeah I think even
Firefox adopted some of them right
because of people just using that and
not the unprofessional yeah I'm not sure
to what extent this has happened but
certainly there was a lot of discussion
about oh my god I guess WebKit prefixed
CSS properties are just a standard some
subset of them and people tied to
implement them and other browsers in it
that just doesn't seem like a good story
and that's part of why I blink does not
have a blink prefix and with that that
says out of time I hope you got your
questions answered and if not do
Barbara's on Twitter or you know here
for the rest of the day and we'll see
what we can do can I have a big round of
applause for our panelists
you